hi there's the coffin here first of all
today I want to announce the winner of
the contest we had where people were
asked to ask me a question a question
that they would want me to answer if we
had a discussion a 30-minute discussion
about language learning so we have a lot
of responses on YouTube Twitter and
Facebook and the winner is Daniel
Candido who is one of my viewers here at
YouTube so first of all Daniel please
contact link support at link comm via
email and we will proceed to set up a
discussion with you by a Skype which we
will also show here at YouTube if it
turns out that the sound and the picture
and so forth are good there were a lot
of good questions asked and so I will be
trying to answer these questions over
the next little while in my videos one
common theme in the questions that I
received was about motivation oh and
before I get into that I should explain
the bedding you see behind me is because
we are installing floor in our little
place here in Palm Springs and so we
were thrown out of our bedroom and we
piled our bedding in here behind me in
my little office here so yeah one of the
common themes was motivation and of
course there's two kinds of motivation
that I see in language or any one is the
sort of longer-term motivation that
drives us to want to learn a language
which could be a friend or relative it
could be a trip we want to make it could
be professional reason it could be an
interest in the culture and that kind of
motivation you have to find within
yourself it can be sparked by someone
else it could be sparked or someone you
know or something that happened to you
but you have to get it within yourself
the second kind of motivation is that
motivation that everyday motivation yeah
I would like to learn the language but
today I don't have the time I don't feel
like it I don't want to I'm not getting
anywhere so how do we deal with that
getting us you know at the task every
day and there what I find useful is
having very specific numbers and tasks
so for example in my Arabic where I
sometimes feel that I'm treading water
and not progressing as quickly as I
would like I make sure that every day I
review three of the many stories in
linked stories that I have already gone
through and of course forgot the most
the words that I looked up but I'll go
through three of them at least a day and
I'll do it while listening to the
natural voice and typically you know you
can reset it five seconds so five
seconds and I do it by the way in
sentence view so that five seconds of
the voice corresponds more or less of
the narrator's course to to a sentence
and so I go through three of these a day
that's I have to do that that's a
specific task that I set myself of
course I always listen when I have an
opportunity while in the car doing
dishes going for a walk and so forth I
have observed that because on the
playlist it records how many times
you've listened to these stories and of
course I have listened to the earlier
stories more often than the later
stories and I find that those stories
that I know the best are the ones that I
have listened to at least thirty times
in fact there are even some later
stories that I have listened to more
often and I understand those better so I
know again a very specific mechanical
thing I have to listen at least thirty
times before these stories are gonna
soak in as meaning without me having to
translate other sort of objective
numbers that I'm aware of the goals that
I have to reach I know from experience
that until I have three thousand known
words that we recount them at length I
won't be able to have much of a
conversation with anyone so I'm at 800
known words in Arabic so I'm gonna have
to wait until I reach 3,000 before I
have a discussion with anyone just let
the phone ring so these are some of the
specific number tasks
modern yeah all right
so specific tasks specific milestones
are very useful I know from experience
that when I have thirty thousand known
words I will and not until will I be
able to kind of read newspapers
understand sort of news broadcast things
of that nature I may not be able to but
before that is highly unlikely that I'll
be able to now people will say that the
known words total it means different
things in different languages and
there's so many variations of the words
in Arabic you know they tack on the end
what to the beginning of a word so every
word if you say an a car that's another
word so you know these numbers are not
scientific
you know statistics on how many words
you know but it's an indicator and I
find all of these numerical indicators
that we have a link are very helpful in
terms of guiding us through the sort of
daily tasks shorter term goals and our
ability to follow our progress towards
these shorter term goals that keep us
motivated when even though we have a
long-term goal of wanting to learn a
certain language our motivation Flags in
the short-term and so that's you know my
advice on dealing with short-term
motivation thank you for listening and
Daniel please contact us and so that we
can set up the meeting
thank you bye for now
[Music]